hello my name is Karen warden I'm with
la talk radio's film courage and i'm
here at the 6th annual san diego indie
fest and you know this is true and you
feel making right now in the making we
are in actually an alleyway and
unfortunately you can't smell the aroma
of the stale beer that's with us what we
have this wonderful couch here that we
found and I'm here with the lovely Jenna
Edwards hello who is a producer and
co-founder of math Lloyd entertainment
now I understand that in the darkness
who is going to be the first narrative
to appear on hulu well to premiere
exclusive very for hulu yes ok so in the
darkness is the like you just said the
first narrative feature to premiere
exclusively on hulu it premieres March
30th so please watch and we at match
point entertainment actually decided to
create feature films straight for the
internet now you have this wonderful
theory that you talked about on the
panel and you talk about something like
the 1985 oh yes my theory is that there
are a lot of filmmakers who are stuck in
what I call 1985 where they just
continue to talk about making their
movie and you really can't talk about
making your movie anymore because
there's some kid with a flip camera
recording you talking about making your
movie putting it up online and they have
a movie while you're still talking so I
think that it's important for filmmakers
to really just make quality content and
make good content for them you know for
whatever market you're going to but make
it and get it done and just stop talking
about it there's no more excuses with
knology nowadays so that's my theory
don't be stuck in 1985 hershey pants
that's correct I'm Nick air yeah like
that there yet and um we had talked a
little bit about speaking on creating
content straight for the internet and
someone had brought up in the panel
about whether or not you should make
your content shorter so in the darkness
is actually 60 minutes long and we did
that because well mother nature killed
us on while we were shooting but in
addition we wanted to make it a little
bit shorter than regular features
because we've noticed that internet
viewing they view it was smaller time
spans and and the attention that people
give two projects nowadays is a lot
shorter so it's an experiment being that
were the first ones but we definitely
brought to the content in a little under
what a normal feature would be
considered
so March 30th our 30th please watch
we're really excited to be the first and
it's like I said an experiment and
distribution and hopefully if it works
out more filmmakers will have another
outlet to show their films yeah thank
you
you
you